il y avait plus de cinq ans que dure est
la guerre d'algérie avec cortège dessous
quand le 16 septembre 1959 le général de
gaulle dans un discours célèbre devait
définir comment la france entendait
achevée en algérie son oeuvre de
décolonisation
sociale
on peut maintenant
discerner le moment où les femmes et les
hommes qui habitent l'algérie seront en
mesure
de décider de leur destin une fois pour
toutes librement en connaissance de
cause
compte tenu de toutes les données
algérienne
nationale internationale du problème
je considère comme nécessaire
que ce recours à l'auto détermination
soit programmé aujourd'hui
au nom de la france et de la république
en vertu du pouvoir que ma tribu la
constitution de consulter les citoyens
pourvu que dieu me prête vie et que le
peuple m'écoute
je m'engage
à consulter
les algériens dans leurs douze
départements
au sujet du destin qu'ils veulent
adopter
malgré le retentissement considérable de
ce discours malgré plusieurs rappels le
fln hésitait lorsque le 14 juin 1960
une fois de plus
au nom de la france
je me tourne
vers les dirigeants de l'insurrection
je leur déclare que nous les attendons
ici
pour trouver avec eux
une fin honorable au combat qui se
traînent encore
réglé la destination des armes
assurer le sort des combattants
ensuite tout sera fait pour
que le peuple algérien est la parole
dans l'apaisement
la décision ne sera que la sienne
mais je suis sûr pour ma part
qu'il prendra celle du bon sens
accompli en union avec la france
et dans la coopération des communautés
la transformation de l'algérie
algérienne
en un pays prospère et fraternelle
quelques jours après ce discours à tunis
les dirigeants de la rébellion par la
voix de leur porte-parole mohamed yazid
déclaré accepter la négociation et ce
fut le 25 juin l'ouverture la préfecture
de melun d'une conférence qui se termine
à quatre jours plus tard rien d'autre
qu'une conversations préliminaires
cependant en france le 17 décembre et à
plusieurs reprises le parlement
approuvait des majorités importante la
politique définie par le chef de l'état
il restait à la faire ratifier par le
peuple ce fut l'objet du référendum du 8
janvier 1961 précédée d'une campagne qui
vit s'affronter toutes les tendances de
l'opinion et qui informe a précisément
tous les citoyens le référendum devait
permettre aux français de répondre à la
question suivante approuvez vous le
projet de loi soumise au peuple français
par le président de la république
concernant l'auto détermination des
populations algériennes et sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics en
algérie avant l'autodétermination
la participation électorale en france et
en algérie fut très importante la
réponse fut massive plus de 75% des
électeurs de voter rui en métropole en
algérie même où le scrutin se déroulera
normalement
69% des suffrages approuvait la
politique d'autodétermination
il fallut cependant attendre quatre mois
occupé peut-être par des contacts
discrets pour que la négociation s'ouvre
à nouveau à evian la france par la voix
de monsieur joxe annoncé en même temps
officiellement qu'elle décrétait une
trêve unilatérale d'une durée de 1 mois
en algérie les délégués algérien au
nombre de huit refusèrent de s'associer
à cette trêve mais la conférence s'ouvre
il cependant
conférence officielle chaque soir des
conférences de presse tenues par les
porte-paroles faisait le point des
progrès enregistrés ou des difficultés
rencontrées porte-parole français
monsieur thibault
ou porte-parole algérien monsieur malek
et le 13 juin après trois semaines de
discussions c'est monsieur joxe lui-même
qui annonça aux journalistes que les
pourparlers n'ont pas rompu mais
interrompu en effet le 20 juillet ces
pourparlers reprenait à lugrin il devait
durer huit jours des progrès importants
ont été réalisés mais l'accord n'était
pas encore possible
quand le 28 juillet les deux délégations
décidèrent d'interrompre à nouveau leurs
discussions à la demande des
négociateurs fln
on sait maintenant qu elles reprirent au
mois de février dernier dans un secret
absolu une maison déposé chaussée du
jura vu mettre au point entre trois
ministres français les délégués du fln
un projet d'accord permettant
l'ouverture d'une négociation officielle
ce projet d'accord
le conseil des ministres français après
avoir entendu messieurs joxe buron et de
breuil les négociateurs de la france ce
projet d'accord le conseil des ministres
l'approuva le 21 février dernier
de son côté à tripoli le cnra se
réunissaient durant une semaine en grand
secret et le 28 février à tunis
mohammedia zidane on cède aux
journalistes que le fln acceptait
également ce projet d'accord
la dernière négociation pouvait s'ouvrir
elle s'ouvrir le 6 mars à evian encore
la délégation française était la même
que celle des pourparlers secrets
monsieur joxe la conduisait messieurs
bureau et de breuil représentait avec
lui le gouvernement de la france
avec les négociateurs du fln il fut
décidé que cette réunion bien
qu'officiel garderait le secret sur ses
délibérations mais cette dernière phase
de la négociation fut plus longue et
plus difficile qu'on ne le croyait à son
début il y eut même des jours
d'inquiétude
mais finalement l'esprit de négociation
l'emporta et cette conférence d'evian
devait bien être la dernière et aboutir
aux accords que vous connaissez qui met
fin à la guerre d'algérie
oui
coups de sabre en ouvre un homme en deux
c'est ça berlin chaque moitié soudain
s'aperçoit qu'elle a besoin de l'autre
comme si un autre mur invisible celui-là
avait traversé en une nuit les amours
les amitiés les familles regardez par
exemple cette scène entre une mère et
une fille la fillette à l'ouest la mer à
l'est elles pourraient encore se parler
mais elles ne sont pas seules à quelques
mètres de là il y a une voiture avec des
policiers de l'est alors la mère a peur
de se compromettre et elle s'en va
et le spectacle le plus hallucinant de
berlin c'est un secteur français à la
bernauer strasse qu'on le rencontre du
côté est les maisons elles mêmes se sont
changés en mur les soupirail les
fenêtres ont été murées
alors chaque soir on assiste à une
grande migration l'est et l'ouest vont à
la rencontre l'un de l'autre vers ce mur
qui les force à lever la tête les
rendant étrangement semblables à des
poissons qui chercheraient de l'air sur
tous ces visages on peut mettre un nom
celui de l'autre visage de l'autre côté
du mur
quel est ce non écoutés
bonne semaine à monaco
le mans france
à paraître
le 13 août cet homme lui attendait sa
mère qui habite de l'autre côté écouter
son histoire votre mère habite l'est
monsieur oui ma mère habite le faubourg
de bale en a
au sud-est de la ville est la deuxième
rejoindre le 23 ou pourquoi le 23 parce
que c'était une date fixée par les
déménageurs le déménageur de l'est qui
seule est autorisée à faire le
déménagement dont le sens est ouest oui
et forcément le 23 que c'était la seule
date libre pour lui oui et
malheureusement ce sont les événements
du 13 ou wii qui se sont interposés elle
n'a pas pu venir par conséquent non
est-ce que vous avez su comment ça
s'était passé oui ma mère n'a écrit deux
lettres entre temps et
si vous
aimez écrire au 23 août alors le jour
même où elle nous elle devait venir
c'est aujourd'hui le jour où je devais
vous rendre chez un enfant mais
malheureusement ça ne s'est pas
passibles d r j'ai vu le déménageur
mais il n'a pas l'autorisation de
quitter le secteur oriental
je suis tellement désespérée
je suis assise entre les deux entre les
annaba dont je bégaie je suis assise
entre les sacs les hamas a démenti
depuis écrit quelques phrases très
désespérée elle
exprime par action de 10 et le plus se
réveiller comme ça et c'est très
compréhensible parce que je continue les
meubles sont vendus le logement et louis
à l'autre à d'autres rues à d'autres
personnes
le sait pas quoi faire
jean paul sartre n'aimant pas être filmé
les images de lui sont rares celle ci
date de l'hiver dernier alors que jean
paul sartre arrivait à prague le voici
en compagnie de simone de beauvoir
que voilà pour y assister à la première
à la première en tchécoslovaquie bien
sûr de sa pièce les séquestrés d'altona
sartre m écrire pour le théâtre et des
mouches aux séquestrés d'altona en
passant par huis clos la respectueuse
les mains sales le diable et le bon dieu
et d'autres encore il a beaucoup donné
au théâtre et le théâtre lui a beaucoup
rendu
ici sur ces images ce fut son dernier
grand succès public mais il y en eut
tant d'autres avant partout dans le
monde et d'abord à paris bien sûr
des succès souvent accompagné le
scandale et de controverses d'ailleurs
sartre a bâti toute sa vie d'homme et
d'écrivain sur l'engagement il croit que
l'écrivain doit se battre et milité
comme tout autre homme il a donné
beaucoup de coups au figuré et
quelquefois au propre il en a évidemment
reçu quelques uns aussi disons que ce
petit homme est un philosophe musclée
puisque le philosophe en lui est ce
qu'il y a plus importants et qu'au fond
tous ses écrits romans essais pièces
sont l'illustration d'une certaine idée
de l'homme qu'on appelle
l'existentialisme mais ceci est une
autre histoire
toute la journée les journalistes
françaises et étrangers ont cherché à
joindre jean paul sartre mais aussi bien
rue schoelcher où se trouve
l'appartement de simone de beauvoir que
boulevard raspail où il habite depuis
deux ans nulle trace de jean paul sartre
et là même où il vit tous les jours peu
de gens le connaissent seule sa
concierge et le patron du restaurant où
il se rend fréquemment peuvent nous
parler du tout
voit dans ce métier je ne connais pas
ses capacités évidemment mais enfin il a
surtout eu horreur des journalistes les
horreurs de ben oui il me dit toujours
surtout pas de journalistes savaient que
c'était un homme qui n'aime pas la
publicité y en a et à la paire centrale
à lillers et que pensez vous lisez un
prix nobel mais mon dieu j'ai lu
quelques livres
j'ai lu les mots le dernier il a
dédicacé d'ailleurs
et il donne un aperçu de sa vie
et de ce refus du prix nobel
oui oui je la refuse il m'a dit oui j'ai
mes idées voilà exactement ce qu'il a
dit
il souvent jean paul sartre puisqu'il
vient fréquemment déjeuner ou dîner chez
vous oui commencez vous de lui
je crois d'abord paul bulcke et ans qui
est absolument charmant toujours très
courtois et très agréable que pensez
vous de ce prix nobel qui viennent de
lui être attribué bien je pense qu'il le
mérite d'abord ça c'est pas tout et de
ce refus aussi ça c'est son affaire je
suppose que s'il a refusé il avait des
raisons pour le faire et que ces raisons
il a dû les exprimer peut-être
l'interrogé vous parce que il nous l'a
pas voulu vous répondrais oui mais pas
plus de joindre il est très dur et que
les journalistes non je crois qu'il
n'est pas très dur mais justement c'est
une position de de son esprit que de
rester en dehors des des compétitions
littéraire ou autre il écrit et je
suppose même qui doit écrire plutôt pour
son plaisir que pour le plaisir des eaux
enfin le pet gens commencent à fuser ce
prix nobel ne voulait absolument pas ça
ne m'étonne pas c'est dans son
personnage
jacques ii
nous savons tous c'est la louche
ex-monarque exposant la tchèque svoboda
tchèque s'envola
le 18 avril 1969 alexander double
tchèque le premier chef de parti
communiste pouvoirs qui ait voulu donner
au socialisme à visage humain a dû sous
la pression de l'union soviétique céder
sa place dur gusztav ou sacs qui
patiemment attendait dans le sombre et
dans celle du général sloboda que
l'invasion du pays par l'armée rouge
commence à porter ses premiers fruits
politique contrairement à ce que l'on
croyait le départ de l'idole du tchèque
n'a pas fait se lever en tchécoslovaquie
un vent de révolte
cela peut s'expliquer par la
personnalité même de son successeur
gustavo ou sacs dont françois fecteau
auteur d'une remarquable histoire des
démocraties populaires ou parle
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
stalinien un orthodoxe
oui je dirais que c'est bien un
communiste orthodoxe
mais il n'est pas de stalinien il ya
aussi des communistes orthodoxes non
stalinien par exemple là parmi les chefs
communistes ils sont actuellement au
pouvoir dans les pays de l'est il y
avoue marie jo c'est ce qu
il est bien rodée cox il se réclame du
marxisme léninisme
mais en même temps on sait qu'il a une
passion pour l'indépendance de son pays
c'est aussi un être humain
il me semble que vous ac appartient à
cette espèce de deux communiste depuis
son entrée sur la scène politique on l'a
toujours connu comme communiste assez
dur à ces fanatiques certes mais en même
temps comme comme patriote qu'en ce
moment ce que l'on pourrait penser je
crois que c'est un homme dont les
qualités intellectuelles sont
supérieures à celles de double tchèque
oui je suis donc dès que d'objets qui
n'est pas une intellectuelle il n'a pas
une formation d'intellectuels
oublié il a fait ses écoles heures
plus tôt dans l'appareil du parti car
l'université tandis que tandis que vous
n'êtes que vient d'une famille
bourgeoise de bratislava
il est assez représentatif même de cette
année intelligentsias slovaque
ses amis parle de lui même ses ennemis
je pouvais dire comme
go
offert ce qui veut dire dans sa carrière
aussi c'est qu'il a été victime lui même
du stalinisme
il a été victime bien bien sûr
il a été victime justement pour cent
pour son 4 3 % pour ce qu'on appelait le
nationalisme bourgeois
il était le chef de la résistance anti
nazie le chef de l'insurrection de cette
famille d'instruction sovac de
1944 et vous savez que cette
insurrection
ne se dirigeait pas seulement contre
contre le gouvernement presque nazis en
tout cas fasciste de tison et contre
contre la même mise nazis un des buts de
cette insurrection est elle à
l'établissement d'une slovaquie sinon m
descendante mais en tout cas très
autonome dans le cadre de l'état
tchécoslovaque reste y aura constitué et
coursac à la tête de son mouvement est
soutenu à cette époque là aussi par les
résistants non communiste pâme opinion
sovac a réussi à hollande mains de la
guerre imposée à imposer cette
conception à prague et il est devenu
président du conseil des commissaires
slovaque et en cette qualité là il a il
a beaucoup fait pour ce pur pour
l'autonomie slovaque et cela jusqu'au
lendemain du coup de prague lorsque le
gouvernement à ce moment-là tout à fait
staline ise de gottwald
a voulu enlever aux eaux sauvages tous
les restes de leur autonomie et boussac
résistant à cette emprise
centralisatrice bureaucratique de trades
s'est attiré les foudres de vos toiles
il a été annoncé comme comme
nationalistes bourgeois il a été privé
de ses fonctions il a été arrêté il a il
a subi une longue toge tiges et son
prestige dans le pays vient du fait que
contrairement à beaucoup de ses
coreligionnaires dirais-je à beaucoup
d'autres communiste qui étaient victimes
de la terreur lui il a tenu bon et spa
il a résisté à la torture c'était un
déshonneur avec ce nul comme ce qui
était son ami de son ennemi politique
joseph smirnov ce qui pour les jeunes et
pour les libéraux les plus avancées et
est indubitablement plus encore qu
alexandre do check le chef de file des
démocrates
pour moscou c'est lui qui menait la
contre révolution il a été éliminé du
président
on sait que il a dit la vérité
vous ac lorsqu'il affirmait qu avec lui
il ne peut être question d'un retour en
arrière vers le régime sioniste vers les
camps d'internement vers les procès
spectaculaire il avait même trop
souffrir tout cela on sait mais on pense
que dieu qui l'a qu'il surestime sais
c'est ses propres possibilités et que
six ans le premier temps il remplit ses
obligations envers le cède à la pression
soviétique à l'encontre de la presse
allait à l'encontre de l'opinion si
l'état vit sa dictature
alors après il sera beaucoup plus facile
aux agents aux agents infiltrés n'est ce
pas à tous ses agents qui depuis depuis
le mois d'août ne cesse de noyauter la
police secrète l'appareil du parti c'est
qu'il le sera à ce moment la plus faste
plus facile sensiblement plus facile des
castes et coussac lui même est
d'installer en slovaquie un régime sans
de boules sans conservateurs comme on
dit là bas c'est à dire
et
inconditionnellement pour soviétique
c'est l'attitude de la population
ouvrière qui causa au russe après
l'occupation la plus grande surprise si
à prague même la prétendue
contre-révolution s'expliquer par la
présence des intellectuels rien a priori
ne justifiait dans les cités ouvrières
comme ici à mlada boleslav
l'attitude de la population face aux
soldats ce biais
nous avons rendu visite à une famille
puis recueilli quelques témoignages au
hasard de la rue à quoi correspond
l'occupation russe pour une famille
quelque chose d'assez
quand nous sommes obligés d'être ici
avec et vivre avec eux
marinisme du rhône amssétou shaders et
anglo arabe et non cessible il doit y
être riche amant mon père dit la dame
dit evans andy et nous étions pour notre
gouvernement pour deux chaînes thermique
et cetera nous avons voulu que tout ça
se réalise leur programme mais à présent
nous devons espérer c'est tout ce que
nous pouvons faire leurs gammes de là
pour venus comme à colomiers en à petit
devant
celle du monde qu'est ce que je vais
traduire alors là si ce fait les risques
partout si que tout le monde a marre de
leur présence ici de manger chez elle
peut sortir le soir
pouvait pas bouger
alors indiquant risque beaucoup de
choses si on est tout à fait son
temps
m
elle dit qu'ils ont déjà violé une fille
de 16 ans c'est bientôt mais là pour ça
à travers le territoire
il raconte qu'un jour les russes ont
arrêté un ingénieur qui travaille à
l'usiné ils ont frappé sans avoir
vraiment la cause pour ça et ensuite
qu'il y avait beaucoup de russes qui se
sont mêlés aussi des habitants devient
tout le monde finalement
est ce qu'on fait de la résistance
passive est ce que je sais pas on refuse
de donner des renseignements russes
ont par exemple
demandé le sens où la direction d'une
île alors les a envoyés
à quelles sont les chances de
l'opposition étudiante les jeunes en
général
je crois que les étudiants eux-mêmes
d'après d'après ce qu'on en sait ne se
font pas beaucoup d'illusions sur le
champ ce média tu comme ça qu'on laisse
les ouvriers les syndicats non plus via
il ya non seulement la résistance des
étudiants de ce maquis qui ont qu'ils
ont fait immédiatement la grève et qui
ont publié des
manifestes où il fait après affirment
leur finalité au programme de
libéralisation démocratisation
le fils c'est comme ça les étudiants ont
réveillé la masse ouvrière ou disons la
population la nation pour le pays mais
parce que les étudiants c'est pas une
classe et c'est disons une couche
sociale plus tôt alors les étudiants ont
pu réveiller mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire maintenant c'est maintenant aux
ouvriers
si on veut changer la situation
c'est plutôt la classe qui travaillent
la place qui est au pouvoir qui peut
changer la situation est ce qu'elle est
d'accord pour changer cette classe
ouvrière oui bien sûr parce qu'il y a
disait centaine de délégations qui sont
bénies chinois la facilité avec spots
pour soutenir soutenir le mouvement et à
draguignan et on a beaucoup discuté les
dernières jours chez nous et il y a
vraiment beaucoup de diesel ya toujours
les étudiants qui vont
dans un souci
il y avait ma centaines de zombies et
qui sont venus chez nous alors que la
vision la lisant fm est là
l'activité
c'est aussi lié
bon sous la grêle sur
voiliers et moi je peux vous dire une
chose spéciale parce que avant j'ai
enseigné dans une usine c'était le cours
de langue française et j'ai fait pour
des ouvriers alors je vous assure il y
avait beaucoup de vriller qu'ils étaient
d'accord c'était pendant la grève eu
beaucoup d'ouvriers qui était d'accord
mais est ce qui a freiné c'était
disons par exemple du recteur ou
l'organisation du parti dans cette usine
c'était ça parce que ce sont des gens
qui vient de la génération après la
guerre le quotidien communiste c'est le
problème ça
au mois d'août dans les rues les jeunes
constituèrent le fer de lance de la
résistance à l'occupation soviétique
personne n'a oublié ces images les
montrent en tentant d'engager un
impossible dialogue avec de très jeunes
soldats dont la plupart ne savaient pas
où il se trouve et où pensez peut-être
en manoeuvre quelque part en allemagne
admirable résistance passive de tout un
peuple uni derrière ces chefs
emprisonnés leur permettant finalement
de s'asseoir à moscou à la table de
conférence
mal préparés sur le plan politique le
déploiement de force échoué aujourd'hui
c'est sous la menace d'une nouvelle
intervention que le marshall gretsch qu
a pu imposer la mise à l'écart ou double
tchèque sverkos ski c'est opecst même et
tant d'autres
la mort tragique de jan valach
l'émouvante unanimité du deuil qui
suivit ne soulevait pas de réaction de
la part des soviets
on
le prétexte sofrito lendemain de la
victoire de l'équipe de hockey de
tchécoslovaquie sur celle de l'urss où
des incidents anti soviétique furent
montées de toutes pièces par des
provocateurs mais les à la foule je
crois que en font un premier temps tout
de même
ou sacs
réussira à à neutraliser toutes ces
résistances tout c'est toute cette
opposition quand même à l'immobilisme
position de la police il y a il ya le
parti où il rétablit elle est en train
de rétablir une discipline de fer tout
cela tout cela marchera mais je crois
que les semences du printemps politiques
continueront à germer les
tchécoslovaques se sont interrompus
maintenant des habitudes de liberté
les seuls fleurs du printemps de prague
1969 sont celles qui ont été déposés sur
les tombes de jan palach et des
massacres
q
première fois découvrez enfin c'est à
dire que deux faits ici nous que pour la
semble bien pour elle
non plus
l'administration a décidé de déclarer la
loi ça qu'ils sont dans la sambre donc
il veut tuer son boss politiquement
exactement savoir ce que maintenant nous
allons faire coïncider ration est
nouvelle
ils se sentent menacés par les étudiants
d'extrême droite shitov cherchait à
rentrer à la samba et un vrai contre-feu
matériel complet anti fasciste
la police entre dans la cour de la samba
les
régimes fascistes les réactionnaires le
salon
il m'a serré vous faites quelque chose
mais rien l'aria fait a pour tout le
monde les merlus il a mal à l'oreille se
feront les redmen